the first step in deploying the
kubernetes is putting your app inside a
container but why stop there
in this episode of kubernetes best
practices let's explore how you can
create small and secure container images
[Music]
thanks to docker creating container
images has never been simpler specify
your base image add your changes and
build your container while this is great
for getting started using the default
base images can lead to large images
full of security vulnerabilities most
docker images use Debian or a bun - as
the base image while this is great for
compatibility and easy onboarding these
base images can add hundreds of
megabytes of additional overhead to your
container for example simple nodejs and
go hello world apps are around 700
megabytes your application is probably
only a few megabytes in size so all
additional overhead is wasted space and
a great hiding place for security
vulnerabilities and bugs so let's look
at two methods to reduce the container
image size using small base images and
using the Builder pattern using smaller
base images is probably the easiest way
to reduce your container size chances
are your language or stack that you're
using provides an official image that's
much smaller than the default image for
example let's take a look at our nodejs
container going from the default node 8
to note 8 alpine reduces our base image
size by 10 times to move to a smaller
base image update your docker files to
start with a new base image now unlike
the old on build image you need to copy
your code into the container and install
any dependencies in the new docker file
the container starts with the node
Alpine image creates a directory for the
code install dependencies with NPM and
finally starts the node.js server with
this update the resultant container is
almost ten times smaller if your
programming language or stack doesn't
have an option for a small base image
you can build your container using raw
alpine linux as a starting point this
also gives you complete control over
what goes inside your containers now
using a small base image is a great way
to quickly build small containers but
you might be able to go even smaller
using the Builder pattern with
interpreted languages the source code is
tend to interpret
and this is executed directly but with a
compiled language the source code is
turned into compiled code beforehand
now with compiled languages the
compilation step often requires tools
that are not needed to actually run the
code so this means that you can remove
these tools from the final container
completely to do this you can use the
Builder pattern the code is built in the
first container and then the compiled
code is packaged in the final container
without all the compilers and tools
required to make the compiled code so
let's take a go application through this
process first let's move from the on
build image to alpine linux in the new
doctor file the container starts with a
go lang alpine image then it creates a
directory for the code copies in the
source code builds the source and then
finally starts the app this container is
much smaller than the on build container
but it still contains a compiler and
other go tools that we really don't need
let's extract just the compiled program
out and put it into its own container so
you might notice something strange about
this doctor file it has two from lines
the first section looks exactly the same
as the previous docker file except that
it uses the asked keyword to give this
step a name in the next section there's
a new from line this will start a fresh
image and instead we'll use the instead
of using go lang alpine we will use raw
alpine as the base image for all alpine
Linux doesn't have any SSL Certificates
installed which will mix most API calls
over HTTP fail so let's install some
root CA certificates and now comes an
interesting part you can use the copy
command to copy the compiled code from
the first container into the second this
line will copy just that one file and
not the rest of the go tooling this new
multistage docker file contains a
container image that's just twelve
megabytes the original container image
was seven hundred megabytes that is
quite a difference using small base
images and the Builder pattern are great
ways to create much smaller containers
without a lot of work and depending on
your application stack there may be
additional ways to reduce your container
image size as well but do small
containers actually have a measurable
advantage let's look at two areas where
small containers shine performance and
security for performance let's look at
how long it takes to build the container
push it to a registry and then pull it
down from the registry for the initial
build you can see that the smaller
container has a huge advantage over
larger containers docker will cache
layers so subsequent builds will take
very little or time for either but for
many CI systems that folks use to build
and test containers they don't cache
layers so there is a significant
time-saving here just think about how
many times you're building and testing
your code now the container is built you
need to push it to a container registry
so you can use it in your kubernetes
cluster I recommend using the Google
container registry you only pay for the
raw storage and network there's no
additional fee to manage containers it's
private and secure and it's lightning
fast in fact GCR uses many tricks to
speed up pushing you can see that the
time to push both the containers for the
large machine is almost the same this is
because GCR uses a global cache for
common base images meaning you don't
need to upload them at all with the
small machine the cpu it becomes the
bottleneck and you can see there's still
a significant advantage to use small
containers if you're using Google
container registry I highly recommend
using Google container builder as part
of your build system as you can see it's
much faster to build and push then even
the large machine and you get a hundred
and twenty build minutes free per day
which should be enough to cover most
people container building needs now
comes the most important performance
metric pulling the container while you
might not care about the time it takes
to build and push the container you
should really care about the time it
takes to pull the container for example
let's say you have a three node cluster
and one of the notes crashes if you're
using a managed system like google
kubernetes engine the system will
automatically spin up and you know to
take its place however this new node
will be completely fresh and I'll have
to pull all our containers before it can
start work
if it takes too long to pull the
containers this is just time where your
cluster isn't performing as well as it
should now there are many cases where
this may occur just adding a new node to
your cluster upgrading your nodes or
even switching led to a new container
for your deployments so minimizing pool
times becomes key you can easily tell
the smaller container is much faster
than the large container and you're
probably running multiple containers on
your kubernetes cluster so these times
can add up quickly using small common
base images for your containers
significantly speeds up the deployment
times and speed at which new kubernetes
nodes can come online now let's look at
security people often say that
containers are more secure if they're
smaller because they have less surface
area for attacks let's see if this is
actually true
an awesome feature of Google container
registry is that it can automatically
scan your containers for vulnerabilities
so I built book the on build and
multistage containers a few months ago
let's see if there's any vulnerabilities
in these old images Wow
there's only three medium
vulnerabilities for the small container
but 16 critical and over 370 for the
larger container if we drill into the
larger container we can see that most of
the issues have nothing to do with their
app but rather programs that we're not
even using when people talk about an
increased surface area for attacks this
is what they're referring to
so remember build small containers the
performance and security benefits are
real I'll see you on the next episode of
kubernetes best practices
[Music]